just when you thought it was safe to go
back to your normal political order
kovid strikes again
according to a new report from deadline
covid mask mandates are returning to
Hollywood with Lionsgate as the first
major Studio to officially reinstate
masking and daily testing the covid
rules are apparently also returning to
campus as well with Morris Brown College
in Atlanta reinstating mask mandates and
other safety protocols
what's strange is the timing most places
dropped the covid mandates two and a
half years ago so you can't even say
that this is a seasonal thing that every
fall we're just going to need to mask up
again or something
we didn't mask up last fall
we didn't even mask up the fall before
that
and on top of all that we now know
thanks to a study from Cochrane Library
the most rigorous and comprehensive
analysis of scientific studies conducted
on the efficacy of masks reported even
by the liberal New York Times that the
masks do absolutely nothing to stop the
spread of covid we also now know thanks
to an admission by the former FDA
commissioner that the social distancing
rule of six feet was completely
arbitrary we also now know that the
vaccines didn't do basically anything
that we were told they would do they
didn't stop people from Catching covid
they didn't stop people from spreading
kovid they weren't necessary they
weren't particularly safe and the
mandates to take them were not
constitutional
we now know all of that and still
still the liberal Elite appears eager to
bring it all back
two and a half years later
right on time
covid-19
arrived the year before the 2020
presidential election that's what the 19
stood for 2019.
end covid-19 Justified the complete
upending of election rules to remove
barriers to fraud and to favor Democrats
even in violation of for example the
Pennsylvania state constitution
and now
right on time 15 months before the 2024
presidential election what do you know
that same malleable little virus appears
to be cropping up again
covid statistics have been notoriously
dubious from day one
but Donald Trump's poll numbers have not
been so dubious they seem to be pretty
reliably high and increasing actually
the liberal establishment is going to
try to throw him in jail first but if
they don't manage to lock him up rest
assured Plan B is to lock you up again
instead I'm Michael knowlesus the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers get
great meat at a secure price and 30
bucks off your order with my code null
skin awles go to goodranchors.com use my
code Knowles today then you can have
steak and eggs for breakfast like me
major Scandal unfolding in Maui the
mayor of Maui won't say how many
children are missing this is a massive
cover-up it's it's basically been
blacked out in the establishment media
we'll get to what's going on and why
that is in just a moment first though
you might say Michael you sound kind of
conspiratorial about kovid what are you
talking about I don't think that the
return the apparent potential Return of
the mass mandates and the lockdowns and
all that kind of stuff that doesn't have
anything to do with the presidential
election
all I'm going to say is
some people got covid right from the
beginning
some people got coveted wrong from the
beginning some people got covered wrong
every single step of the way some people
got it right pretty much every single
step of the way and you know I hate to
say I told you so but I'm at the very
least happy to say that I was in the
former Camp here
I called it guys I called it when
everyone was saying oh well actually
maybe we should mask up I said The Masks
are stupid when everyone said well maybe
we should stay home in Social distance I
said that's ridiculous and I returned to
work within 36 hours even after they
sent me home I called up Jeremy I said I
gotta come back to the studio I'm going
to lose my mind in my apartment
flew around
questioned the vax from day one said it
seemed Preposterous bad idea all these
things okay and so I just like maybe
[Music]
just maybe I look if you're listening to
this show you're probably aware of how
the liberal establishment used covid-19
to its own purposes but the timing here
I don't see how anybody with even a
modicum of Common Sense two brain cells
to rub together could look at this and
say hey covid returns for the first time
in two and a half years
wonder wonder why that is right before
the presidential election what's the
point of that a big point of that
is that Joe Biden is not doing well
against any of the Republicans
Trump continues to lead in the polls
Trump continues to beat Joe Biden
according to head-to-head polls and
Biden's numbers are tanking
so what do they have to do they've got
to rig the system
especially because Joe Biden faces this
this
Hunter Biden issue
that involves Joe Biden because the
hunter Biden corruption wasn't just
about Hunter Biden we now know that Joe
was intimately involved in that we've
got the receipts we've got the emails
we've got the handwritten notes we've
got the pseudonyms we've got the calls
that he set up we've got it all
and now the the Biden Camp doesn't want
to have to deal with this the Joe Biden
Camp the hunter Biden Camp is actually
using it for leverage because Hunter
Biden's lawyer reportedly threatened to
place Joe Biden on the witness stand if
Joe Biden's doj prosecuted Hunter Biden
and didn't give Hunter Biden the
sweetheart deal that the prosecutors
tried to give him before the judge shot
it down
Chris Clark is Hunter Biden's former
lawyer wrote a threatening letter to
prosecutors last October
warning the department not to charge him
said President Biden now unquestionably
would be a fact witness for the defense
in any criminal trial there can be no
doubt that these leaks have inserted
President Biden into the case this of
all cases justifies neither the
spectacle of a sitting president
testifying at a criminal trial nor the
potential for a resulting constitutional
crisis
as a result of this the doj offered
Hunter a sweetheart deal that said yeah
you'll get off the hook for the tax
crimes you'll be diverted you won't even
really be prosecuted for the gun crimes
and we'll just let you off the hook and
then you won't have to deal with any
other future legal problems
now is this an example of Hunter and Joe
being pit off against one another I
don't think so I think I think this is
the Biden family generally threatening
the doj and the administrative
government to say hey man do you want to
cause a constitutional crisis I don't
think so so back away back away and
there's there's some reason for that you
yeah you don't want to cause a
constitutional crisis you want to give
some deference to the president you want
to give a little bit of grace to the
president just so so that you don't have
a group of unaccountable bureaucrats
effectively running the country and
undermining the way that the system was
set up but do you notice that the
government is willing to do anything to
avoid a constitutional crisis with
regard to Joe Biden
and yet they're accelerating a
constitutional crisis with regard to
Trump
this is where you know this well let's
defer to the president let's try to
maintain the Constitutional order this
is how you know it's all Bs it's just a
power grab by the Liberals because the
the fact that they're trying to throw
Trump in prison
on at least four fronts right now and
and probably more by the 2024 election
shows you that they don't really care
about a constitutional crisis what if
what if Donald Trump wins the election
from prison is he going to Pardon
himself what if it's at the state level
what's he going to do is he going to
call in the Federal Marshals to drag him
out of prison of course that's a
constitutional crisis
the mere fact of of Prosecuting the
leader of the political opposition in
the United States is a constitutional
crisis they don't care about that
because they don't care about the
Constitution
they care about maintaining their power
keeping Joe Biden out of trouble keeping
the Biden family money rolling in
keeping America's influence being sold
overseas to the highest bidder so that
the the liberal Elites can continue to
enrich themselves
and
silencing and intimidating and outright
imprisoning the conservative opposition
now when you want to build up your base
of knowledge as an American conservative
you got to check out prageru right now
head on over to prageru.com a majority
of Zoomers support left-wing policies
like open borders and socialism we don't
reach them and change their minds the
country we know and love will be lost
forever prageru is the leading
non-profit when it comes to influencing
young people Gregor use educational
entertaining pro-america videos meet
young people where they are online and
open their minds to the truth but they
need your help go to prageru.com make a
tax deductible donation whatever you
give right now will be tripled and have
three times the impact donate 10 bucks
triples to 30 bucks give a hundred bucks
it explodes to 300 bucks
prageru is 100 free to everyone with no
fees or subscriptions they don't rely on
ads or clickbait headlines contrary to
what the left says prageru is not funded
by a handful of billionaires it's funded
by people just like you in order to keep
making great content reaching millions
and changing Minds prageru needs your
help head on over to
prageru.com to donate today
even with the prosecutions even with all
the threats and the corruption
even with kovid lingering on the horizon
Trump is absolutely crushing in the
polls and I'm giving these updates in
particular because we're now one day out
from the presidential debate but because
the the polls are not all over the place
they're not up and down and up and down
so you say I don't know if I can really
trust the polls or all the polls say the
same thing which is that Russia's Trump
is absolutely dominating not just at the
national level but including in the
early primary states that any potential
Challenger to Trump would have to win to
even have a shot at the nomination
in Des Moines in Iowa the Des Moines
Register says that Trump is up 23 points
right now 42 to 19 for DeSantis and then
Tim Scott is a full 10 points behind
DeSantis followed by Haley Pence
Christie Vivek burgum heard who was
heard
I I remember bergam I actually don't
even remember who hert is okay so it
doesn't matter what about in New
Hampshire right now in New Hampshire
Echelon has as a poll out shows Trump at
34 percent
so not as dominant a lead as he as he
has in Iowa but still he's up 20 points
over the number two guy that's Chris
Christie is anybody seriously believe
that Chris look I'm I'm the biggest
proponent of the chrysosons that there
is very Pro croissants but does anyone
think that Chris Christie is going to
win the Republican nomination for
president not very many people he could
maybe pose a challenge he could mess
things up for for Rhonda santis or Vivek
ramaswamy but
he's probably not going to win it he is
at 14. the vake is at number three with
eleven percent DeSantis is now fourth in
New Hampshire
Iowa New Hampshire South Carolina South
Carolina Trump has I think 150 percent
at this point but Iowa and New Hampshire
DeSantis has got to come in
number one in at least one of those
States
or or a very close number two to have a
shot and he's now number four in New
Hampshire not good news you might say
well it doesn't matter Michael it's
Silly Season we haven't had the first
debate yet people aren't paying a lot of
attention to the race in the summer
people don't really know where they
shake out so who knows maybe DeSantis
will will be able to come back maybe he
will if all of the other candidates drop
out I guess maybe he would have a chance
but this is not like an ordinary
presidential election which is something
I've been trying to impress upon people
we have not seen an election like this
since 1888 the last time we had a
president running for a non-consecutive
second term
the point of its Silly Season no one's
paying attention let's wait until the
debate's kind of rhetoric is the notion
that the American public does not know
the candidates yet so we're going to get
to know the candidates at the debates
everybody knows Trump
everybody already knows him
that's one of the consequences of him
running effectively as an incumbent to
say nothing of the fact that he's been a
celebrity for 40 years
he's not even showing up to the debate
maybe that really hurts his poll numbers
I doubt that it will
so the the people already know the
candidates where is it where's that 34
going to move where's the 42 percent in
Iowa going to move you might say well
that's less than 50 okay let's see if
every other candidate drops out and
somehow the the anti-trump forces
coalesce around one candidate I'm
skeptical that would happen we were all
waiting for that to happen in 2016.
remember all the genius commentators
said that's what's going to happen
there's going to be anti-trump candidate
it'll be Ted Cruz or Marco Rubio and and
or John Kasich they said at the end and
and then that's the person who's going
to get it it never happened Trump just
walked away with the nomination having
had a plurality in pretty much all the
states
so
is it going to be DeSantis I don't know
look I love the guy I don't want it to
sound like I'm down on the guy I really
like him personally he's super smart
he's a very good Governor I'd be
perfectly happy if he were the nominee
for pretty much anything in politics I'm
just looking at the numbers here folks
don't shoot the messenger looking at the
fact it's not looking good for him and
I'm not the only one who's saying that
Rupert Murdoch according to a report has
soured on uh the DeSantis candidacy and
apparently
according to the Washington Post so take
it with a grain of salt he encouraged
Glenn young in Virginia to run in 2024.
and you know yankin has set the stage to
run younken a few months ago released a
national ad that positioned him as a
reagan-esque presidential candidate
it's pretty overwhelming to contemplate
the future of America
it's such an honor to be here with proud
Americans who carry on President
Reagan's cherished Legacy he brought
Peace by projecting strength at a time
when it's easy for us to lose Faith to
worry that we are indeed that one
generation when Freedom becomes extinct
there are lights shining we can usher in
a new era of American values President
Ronald Reagan changed lives
now it's our turn a time to choose life
liberty in the pursuit of happiness over
oppression and dictatorial rule the
stakes are high
and the consequences couldn't be greater
[Music]
so that's that's an ad what's the point
of putting that ad out to announce that
he had a speech in April at the Reagan
Library no the point of putting that ad
out is to test the waters to see if he
can be president he's coming to Atlanta
this Saturday to serve as the closing
speaker at a conference that Eric
Erickson you know Eric Erickson the
conservative writer has organized to
Showcase a bunch of Republican
presidential candidates and all of a
sudden Glenn Younkin shows up
why is he doing this
I don't think he's doing this because
he's going to announce a run for
president I think he would be a lunatic
to announce a run for president I think
he would be absolutely suicidal to
announce a run for president
because he's an attractive candidate he
had a big upset win in Virginia that
actually
some reporting from certain news outlets
that rhyme with Bailey schmeyer seem to
have helped across the finish line
he's an impressive guy
but if he were to declare right now what
is to prevent him from going into the
same exact meat grinder that Ronda
Santos is going into Rhonda Santa is the
most impressive governor in the country
and he has been
brutalized by the Trump campaign machine
what is to stop the same fate from
happening to Klein yankin so then why is
he doing it I think that Glenn young is
doing this one in case something happens
with Trump we're in a really tempestuous
race where they're trying to throw the
guy in an orange jumpsuit so who knows
and we've got two relatively elderly
candidates even though Trump is youthful
and vigorous and all the things he says
he is so I don't know who knows maybe he
ends up not being able to run for one
reason or another and then potentially
young can could jump in at the end or
he's running for VP or he's running for
a cabinet post
but but junkan cannot afford to get on
Trump's bad side
one thing one mistake that people make
in politics is when they look at all
these candidates they assume that the
circumstances surrounding all these
candidates are the same they assume
they're all playing from the same basic
premises oh junkins the governor of
Virginia DeSantis is the governor of
Florida okay so the same calculus
applies it doesn't the reason that
DeSantis is running now is because he's
going to get term limited out two years
before the next presidential race and
people are going to forget about him
over those two years at least that's
what he fears and so he he wants to run
while it's still his moment his big peak
moment of national Fame came during
covid when he stood up against fauci and
when he stood up against all the
mandates and so he has to capitalize on
that because in politics like comedy
timing is everything
he's going to get termed out and then
who knows where he goes
he's got to run even if it's a tough
year juncken is going to get term
limited out
at the end of this term because Virginia
is a weird Commonwealth in Virginia you
can't run consecutive terms for governor
so so Junkin gets elected
he he's elected in 21 he's inaugurated
in 24. he's going to be out in 2026.
it's a four-year term that means he
can't run again until 2029. he can't
even run for a second term until after
the next presidential election
maybe people will forget about him by
then maybe he'll be more seasoned maybe
he at least wants that opportunity to
run again for re-election but who knows
his political future is is much more
precarious and delicate simply by virtue
of the fact that he's from Virginia than
Ron desantises is so he's got to be very
careful if he gets Ground Up by Trump
right now the guy's done is done at the
state level at the national level so his
smart move is going to be to sit in the
background wait for some of these
candidates to get chewed up by Trump and
then potentially either step in if
Trump's been pushed out of the way or
get a nice position by president kofe in
the meantime the potential number two
candidates who are in the race are about
to murder each other in Milwaukee we'll
get to that in one second first though
as I give you a little window into
the political calculation in the GOP
right now let's talk about the windows
in your home let's talk about Renewal by
Anderson right now text nulls to 200
300. for most homeowners window
replacement is not something they've
done before and for many it isn't
something that they want to do but
rather something they have to do if
you've put off replacing the windows in
your home because they're too expensive
I've got great news you can now get a
free in-home window consultation and a
free price quote from Renewal by
Anderson a company that I've known about
for a long time because my cousin works
for that company and I forgot about that
until the other day Renewal by Anderson
signature service is committed to giving
you the best customer experience
possible through the perfect combination
of the best people in the industry a
superior process and an exclusive
product I'm a big fan we're talking
about stuff with your home
get the best get the best Renewal by
Anderson will hook you up to offering a
free in-home or virtual consultation on
top quality affordable windows or patio
doors for zero dollars down zero
payments and zero interest for a year
text Knowles to 200 300 for your free
consultation to save 375 bucks off every
window and 750 bucks off every door
these savings will not last long check
it out by texting nulls to 200 300 that
is nulls to 200 300 texting privacy
policy and terms and conditions posted
to textplan.us texting enrolls for
recurring automated text marketing
messages messenger database May apply
reply stop to opt out go to
windowappointmentnow.com for full offer
details
folks it is here you know things happen
gradually and then suddenly as Andrew
Clavin is fond of quoting Ernest
Hemingway of saying
it took two years to get my set
now we've got it
it took
years to get the yes or no game the
favorite game of everybody out there the
most beloved cherished controversial
internet Game Show game in the world
and then it took what a year a solid
year to get yes or no the conspiracy
expansion pack this box looks excellent
It's A Beautiful pack it's available
right now it's gonna sell out just like
all of the yes or no games sell out so
make sure if you want it you go to
dailywire.com shop we've got a new
episode of yes or no right now with my
friend Eric July every Hollywood
superhero moving forward will be
required to have at least one lgbtq
character shoved into the story what do
you mean moving forward we're already
there buddy
thank you
right now go to dailyr.com shop get your
copy of the yes or no game we still have
some boxes of that they are going to
sell out so if you haven't bought the
game yet make sure you get the game now
if you are ever going to want it and
also
get the yes or no expansion pack I
believe they are still in stock but you
should order them now the super
conspiracy
expansion what's a conspiracy theory
conspiracy theory is a truth six months
early that's what it is
the two guys who are vying for number
two
are going to murder each other they're
at least going to try to murder each
other in Milwaukee on that debate stage
I'm talking about Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis and anti-work businessman the
vague Rama Swami here's my proof
and an article came out yesterday from
ABC
and it it popped up in my Google Alerts
I think or it popped up on my feed I
said why is this popping up I don't have
alerts on Vivek like the guy but you
know I don't I don't monitor us every
move no it's because I mentioned the
daily wire here's the headline
wanting to be famous now the vague
ramaswamy sought podcast stardom
prior to White House run
quote he's been wanting to be famous for
a long time one former aide told ABC
News
well
the politician wanted name recognition
oh gee you don't say stop the
stop this
and commentator and and politician
wanted to get some attention for the
stuff he wants to do can you hold on
so unlike all of those other candidates
who hate Fame who hate influence they
don't want any part of that right okay
so it's this long hit piece from ABC
News
this is weird this is where it involved
the daily wire
said heading into 2022 Rama Swami
hitting to deal and been working with
the popular right-wing Media Company the
daily wire on a project that was
ultimately scrapped according to
multiple sources familiar with the
project the deal was unlike anything the
daily wire had previously done with its
Talent
now before we get to that part I want to
point out I I think we may have
mentioned that we were working with
Vivek on something I mean I've mentioned
obviously he and I go back to college
together Vivek is friends with a number
of us over here I don't think this is
some big super secret thing he's been on
all of our shows we've worked with him
on plenty of stuff they say oh but he
didn't deal he was working with he was
maybe going to work with the daily wire
until he decided to run for president he
was maybe going to do this that or the
other thing but then this is the line
that got me it said the deal was unlike
anything the daily wired previously done
with its Talent the company which in
2022 said it made 200 million dollars
signed ramaswamy in the hope of
developing a show around him
you mean the thing that daily wire's
done with all of its Talent ever that
it's ever hired what do you mean it was
a deal unlike anything we've ever done
we hired a guy and then built a show
around him
what what else are we gonna do we're
going to build a show around it before
we hire him I don't what is the D no
okay maybe they mean it they get
specific here the project which was
scheduled to debut in 2022 would have
seen ramaswamy as the face of a new
podcast oh yeah it's unlike anything
we've ever we've never done podcasts
around here but it's a podcast focused
on politics
and the economy according to multiple
sources familiar with its development
so at this point I'm reading this piece
I say what is even the point of this
piece one pretty weak journalism this is
a deal on like anything the DIY has ever
done literally the exact same thing it's
done with every single person it's ever
hired so and they did that but then it
didn't happen because Vivek started
another company and then ran for
president
but here here's what
here's what it's telling about the piece
when asked for comment on this story
ramaswami's senior advisor Trisha
McLaughlin told ABC News referring to
DeSantis quote does one of your sources
live in a publicly financed mansion in
Tallahassee Florida so the vague team is
accusing the DeSantis team of planting
this story as a hit piece on Vivek now I
don't know if DeSantis had anything to
do with this story or anyone even
associated with DeSantis so who knows
maybe it was Doug burgum maybe it was
Chris Christie uh who I don't have no
idea who it is
but this piece is a pre-debate hit piece
that's all it is because the thesis of
this piece is nothing other than
I don't like Vivek ramaswamy
what's the allegation the allegation is
he wants to be influential
the allegation is he almost had a
podcast like every single white
Millennial male in the country if not
the world
like and and many not podcasting is
particularly concentrated among white
Millennial males but if there are many
other people some women some non-white
people some non-millennials even but a
lot of people have podcasts
what is the
the P it's just wanting to be famous
that's the headline he's a big jerk
that's all it says we don't like Vivek
that's the point the point of this is
this guy's getting a lot a lot of
attention he's got a lot of momentum
going into the debate and so we want to
take him down expect a lot of pieces
like that again I really I'm not
accusing the DeSantis Camp of planting
it if I were in the DeSantis Camp I
would plant something like that so I
don't I think it would be reasonable and
smart for them to do that sort of thing
and I I think that the supposedly leaked
Memo from the DeSantis debate team
saying that DeSantis is going to go
after Vivek really hard in Milwaukee I
think that's probably smart too he has
to because if a vague is the threat in
at least some of the early States and
certainly in the National polls Vivek is
the threat to DeSantis so DeSantis has
to go after Vivek if he doesn't he would
be derelicting his duty as a candidate
his duty to his voters and to his donors
and and to himself into his campaign
the vague for his part is going to have
to go after DeSantis they're vying for
the same position
Chris Christie who's behind both of
those guys by a considerable margin
he's going to have to go after DeSantis
first and then maybe Vivek
he has to even though Christie's whole
campaign is premised on the idea that he
is going to bring the fight to Donald
Trump none of these guys are really
going to bring the fight to Donald Trump
they'll all get some Zinger in there
they'll all have but they'll they will
only be doing that to harm the other
candidates who are actually on that
stage because Chris Christie's not going
to go from 3 to 43 percent like Donald
Trump in one debate it's not going to
happen he's going to have to knock the
other guys out so all of the incentives
for the debate
are going to be for the guys on that
stage to fight each other
that's all it's going to be
you might say well they should just
attack Donald Trump they should just
focus yeah maybe if you know if it were
possible for them to just attack Donald
Trump that would be better for the party
if my Grandma had Wheels she would be a
wagon okay
the incentives are not there which is
what I have said about this race from
the beginning people say well what if we
all just turn on Trump
uh I don't that's I don't think that
would be a good thing but even if that
were a good thing it's not going to
happen guys there are structural issues
built in
now
all of the top candidates this is what I
love so much about the 2024 primary all
of the top candidates
even arguably including Vivek but
certainly Trump and DeSantis are running
relatively illiberal campaigns they're
not running on the same old crap that
we've heard from the GOP and certainly
from the Democrats for 50 years
they're not running on
I don't care what you believe just that
that you think for yourself I don't care
what our students are taught I don't
want to teach them what to think just
how to think I don't listen oh we don't
care about Borders or immigration or
trade deals or people in Middle America
we just care about the free Marketplace
of goods and services in the free
Marketplace of ideas and we don't
believe that anything's true or good or
it right or anything no we're just we're
just whatever man shut up and leave me
alone and cut my taxes none of the top
candidates are running on that at all
Trump is running on build a wall even if
he's not going to do it he's at least
running on build a wall stop Outsourcing
jobs slap a bunch of tariffs on foreign
businesses so we can stop globalization
mercantilism for the 21st century
salute the flag stop being a jerk
believe in make America great again
America used to be greater than it is
today
cut all the crap with liberalism
DeSantis arguably is doing that even
more than Trump
DeSantis goes in he took over a school
in Florida a new college and he said
we're going to kick the wokeness out of
here and we're going to put good people
on the board and we're going to ban bad
things and we're going to encourage good
things and you know I know that the
DeSantis team has gotten in trouble with
the liberal media for supposedly Banning
books and then the squishy people on the
right come in and they say he's not
Banning books he is Banning books and
he's right to ban books he's Banning
gay porn in elementary schools that's a
good thing to do we're for that I'm not
saying we just go out and throw have
Piers of books burning of Shakespeare
and Dante and Milton but we certainly
should ban bad books from kindergarten
classrooms at the very least
book Banning is not it's not the worst
thing in the world every smart person in
history has done it
Plato is in favor of book bands and book
burning
the apostles in the acts in in the New
Testament burn books
the books of the sorcerers in the New
Testament you've got uh
plenty of doctors of the church have
included or have encouraged the Banning
of books the Vatican until very very
recently had a list of prohibited books
and even if you're of a more Protestant
persuasion Martin Luther was a big fan
of burning books okay I'm not saying we
should indiscriminately burn all sorts
of books or be Philistines or be
ignorant or backward or anything like
that but we we have obscenity laws in
this country for a reason there are
certain things that are not conducive to
our virtue or our edification or our
education they're actually contrary to
that that encourage Vice and make us
dumber and more bestial and and that's
the sort of stuff that we should get out
of the Public Square well DeSantis has
done that too even Vivek in his attacks
on the woke corporations and on ESG and
Dei he's running fairly illiberal
campaign
modern classical or otherwise
well we're seeing a really good example
of that outside of our country in
Hungary Hungary just had a celebration
of its nation's birth
in the form of Saint Stephen Day Saint
Stephen was the first king of Hungary
uh this was around the year 1000 and the
the government is actually Justified on
the crown of Saint Stephen so how did
they celebrate they had big festivals
all day long I was just in Budapest it's
a beautiful place and then at the end
they had these drones fly up into the
sky and create an image of the Hungarian
coat of arms then the crown of Saint
Stephen and then this is what was
controversial and crucial pun very much
intended the drones dissolved and formed
into a cross
the Cross of Christ in lights in the sky
to celebrate
the nation's identity
which is part and parcel of the
excellent prime minister over there
prime minister Orban
uh saying that Hungary is not a liberal
democracy it's an illiberal democracy
and what he means by illiberal democracy
he says is Christian democracy
we're a Christian Nation a Christian
democracy
what's so amazing you're going to hear
some Libs Screech about fascism well
it's fascist
everything I don't like is fascist
not only is this not fascist obviously
not only does this have nothing to do
with fascism
not only not only is Victor Urban
popularly democratically elected so they
say he's a tyrant or a dictatory stolen
elections complete BS not only is
Christianity not synonymous with fascism
the fascists are actually rather opposed
to Christianity but
this is the sort of thing that we did in
our own country not so long ago
there's a picture from 1956 Rod Drayer
just pointed this out on Twitter
a picture from 1956 Easter Sunday New
York City the three big buildings big
skyscrapers
all have their Windows the lights turned
on
to be crosses for Easter Sunday
all three like the three crosses on
Mount Calvary
this was New York City 1956 and in 1956
in Hungary the Communists had taken over
and and Christianity was quashed
Christianity was suppressed by that
officially atheistic regime
and Rod made the point he said
what was Unthinkable in Hungary in 1956
is happening today
and what was commonplace in America in
1956 is Unthinkable today
what a switch that is I was thinking
about this the other day because Xi
Jinping the
supposedly communist dictator of
communist China came out and he said
that he was not going to give stimulus
checks to his people because he didn't
want to get hooked on welfareism
in America we never we don't go more
than five minutes without sending
people's stimulus checks
in manipulating our currency
and getting people hooked on all manner
of welfarism I think what a bizarre time
it is when the supposedly communist
dictator of China is more capitalistic
than the United States what a strange
time it is when Hungary under communist
depression officially atheist for 45
years
is more overtly Christian than the
United States which was founded to be a
model of Christian charity a city on a
hill founded by people who call
themselves pilgrims to be a Christian
Nation what the hell happened
you know when Jordan P Peterson made the
decision to join the daily wire
it was a major win
for people who Champion intellectual
debate with one year of unparalleled
output his contributions have set new
standards and remained unmatched by any
other platform daily wire plus now has a
vast array of exclusive Jordan Peterson
content offering hundreds of hours of
captivating content that you will not
find anywhere else
Jordan has created thought-provoking
works that reshape your perspective on
life which include vision and Destiny
marriage and Dragons monsters and men
the ands in Jordan's content make it
very difficult to distinguish one piece
from the next there's so many commas so
many topics Additionally you can immerse
yourself in discussions that nurture
your spiritual side like logos and
literacy and Jordan's Crown breaking
Series in the book of Exodus I haven't
even mentioned his Beyond order lecture
Series where his extensive Archive of
lectures and podcasts this is the
compendium with all things Jordan Plus
there's even more new exclusive content
on the horizon it's only the beginning
by becoming a daily wire plus member you
will embark on an unforgettable
experience who will fuel your thirst for
knowledge and Inspire personal growth
like never before go to dailywire.com
subscribe to become a member today my
favorite comment yesterday is from Alex
Clare
who says is Michael now the boss of
Jeremy and Ben or something his set Is
Now by far the coolest thank you very
much you know Jeremy is often hungry
Ben is in Florida
when the cat's away the mice will play
this is I I decided Well everyone was
out of Nashville I was going to take all
the resources of the daily wire
stop them from going to any other silly
project that we don't need and funnel
them all into my set
and I think it was money well spent okay
I think it was money well
spent
before we move on from Hungary I really
like I was very impressed by Hungary
the the final objection that people are
going to make to a big cross in the
skies they're gonna say well what if you
don't believe in Christianity
what if you don't believe in the rainbow
flag
I don't believe in the rainbow flag I
believe in the rainbow which is a sign
of God's promise never to destroy the
world again in a flood
I believe but the rainbow flag is
something else I don't believe in it I
don't think it's true as a matter of
human nature I don't think it's good as
a matter of virtue and I think that
Pride which it represents is the queen
of all Vice so I I'm quite opposed to
the rainbow flag
Obama lit the White House up in a
rainbow flag
Joe Biden just put not only the rainbow
flag but the kind of terrorist rainbow
flag you know the really threatening one
with the BLM and all that kind of stuff
put that right in the center of the
White House Portico
flanked by American flags an obvious
violation of flag code
just say this is our sacred symbol
all cultures are going to have sacred
symbols in Hungary what they say is
I heard this from the mouth of the
government ministers
they say look we don't we don't really
care what you personally believe and
they prove it too the Jewish quarter for
instance in Budapest is probably the
nicest Jewish quarter anywhere in the
world including Israel
beautiful vibrant really nice fun bars
second largest synagogue in the world so
they obviously are quite tolerant of
people who have other religious views
but they say but it's a political matter
we're a Christian country the country is
justified by the crown of Saint Stephen
and so that's as a political matter that
that's what we're going to order our
country around the cross stands still As
the World Turns it's the axle on which
the World Turns okay and that's going to
be our national identity our national
identity right now is a bunch of fruity
rainbow flags and people doing all sorts
of decadent vicious things
it's not good you're going to have a
symbol either way what's it going to be
what are we going to light up in the sky
to what will we pay homage and declare
our loyalty and obeisance
speaking of our Brave New World
Cuba
has just taken a major step toward a
cashless economy
Cuba which makes sense it's a tiny
little communist island nation so
they've got a lot of control over the
economy there the Cuban government just
said that entrepreneurs can no longer
take out more than 5 000 pesos in cash
that's 20 bucks
businesses can no longer take out more
than 20 bucks a day in cash
which is going to force the businesses
to do their transactions electronically
which is going to give the government a
greater ability to spy on the citizens
and figure out what kinds of things
they're purchasing control uh black
markets obviously but also to control
what goods are being legally purchased
if they don't like the Cubans are buying
too too many beans they'll shut down
that if they don't like that the Cubans
are buying too many cigars they want to
ship the cigars off to more lucrative
markets like in China they're going to
shut that down too and this sort of
thing is coming to the United States
there's a push for a digital currency
here you saw this during covet this was
one of the uh convenient consequences of
covid lockdowns for the liberal
establishment is that there was a coin
shortage you remember so sorry we just
can't take cash I guess you're gonna
have to pay online and then we're going
to have to see your bank statements and
then we're going to have to shut down
your money political distance have had
their Banks shut down you saw this with
Nigel farage in the UK it's not just in
the U.S either in the UK Nigel farage
may drop position leader over there was
debanked because they don't like what he
does they don't like his political
activities after all that's the man
behind the brexit
that's that's going to happen here so
what are we going to do about it we
should resist it
we should definitely resist it but
it's most likely going to happen
our our individual use of cash is not
going to stop this our cultural coming
together through Civic associations to
say we're going to use cash it's not
going to stop it
we need a political solution
this is where the politics is Downstream
of culture thing Falls flat
this is where the libertarian dream that
we can all just act individually and
that will reshape the political order
comes up a little bit short
this is happening this will happen short
of political action to stop it
we're going to have the cashless aside
even with political action we might have
it but that's going to be the only shot
we have of stopping it
now this will the political action will
be spurred in part by individuals
gathering together in various cultural
ways the the Biden Administration
couldn't push the vaccine mandate until
enough Americans had voluntarily taken
the vaccine
that it had a a significant base of
political support that the remaining
people wouldn't be able to cause too
much trouble
that's true it's a complex interplay of
features but we need a political
solution and it's a nice sign in the GOP
that the top candidates all recognize
that fact and to the candidates who
might be more inclined to get rid of the
government or not use the hand of the
state or whatever they're all polling in
the single digits right now uh before we
go before we go
Maui
the the mayor of Maui
will not say how many children are
missing what we've been told is that
officially there are about 100 people
who have died in the fires
but there are a thousand people missing
missing now how many days later here's
where the mayor of Maui has to say
I don't know yes you do
how many children are missing
you guys
this is one of the biggest questions
[Music]
oh we could say that about you you've
ruined it for everyone yeah you're the
media you can say whatever you want
you're a disaster all right okay
[Music]
good on the journalist I'm all for being
respectful in these these kinds of
things but first of all there aren't
that many journalists there so the mayor
of Maui's trying to deflection so it's
not your turn it's not your turn give me
an answer how many kids are missing oh
we don't we don't know yeah we don't
know no big deal okay moving on he says
what the hell you mean you don't know
you don't know
days later this seems like a cover-up
yeah well someone sometimes one of these
guys is going to ruin it for everybody
ruin it for everybody these like five
journalists here you're not answering
the most important question what's going
on
this is most likely a major scandal
the Liberals tried to deflect and say oh
the Maui fires they were caused by
global warming it was the sun monster
okay look away No One Believes that no
serious person believes that so the
question is was it the incompetence of
the
government that should have mitigated
the threat of wildfires that
acknowledged the threat four years ago
and did nothing about it because it
diverted all of its resources into
fighting this the sun monster the
imaginary
scary catastrophic apocalypse man in the
sky or
was it arson we know that there's been a
ton of arson set off by radical
environmentalists in Maui and throughout
the rest of the world in recent years we
know that there are hundreds of these
incidents that occur regularly
so which is it
either way not good and now we hear
potentially a thousand people lots of
them children just burned alive the
roadblocks complete mismanagement every
time
an illegal alien child at the border
caught a cold
during the Trump Administration it was
National headline news AOC pretending to
cry outside the gates
but a thousand people potentially dead
in Maui many of them if not most of them
children and nothing nothing a media
blackout blackout from the the mayor
should be a major national scandal
nothing which doesn't tell you very much
about the Maui Administration doesn't
tell you very much about global warming
it tells you a lot about the media
that's what it tells you and tells you a
lot about how the liberal establishment
in this country works and how the
political order Works especially as we
approach
elections got other got other focuses
here we got to worry about covid folks
rest of the show continues now you don't
want to miss it become a member and use
code Knowles Canada wlas at checkout for
two months free on all annual plans it
is Tuesday you know I can't talk about
on YouTube where they'll cast me into
the outer Darkness so we talk about it
in my brand new set on Tuesday we'll see
over there in a minute
foreign
[Music]